Speaker 1: Well, Sarah Palin is really having
a tough one. It turns out a lot of people
in Alaska just don't like her. Sarah Palin,
you might remember, former mayor of Wasilla,
former governor of Alaska, although she quit that
job, former running mate to the late Senator John
McCain in 2008. She was the vice presidential
running mate. She is now running for the House
of Representatives. She was on the phone with Real
America's Voice, which I guess is Steve Bannon.
This is the war room, Steve Bannon's show. And
she is very triggered that her fellow Republican,
Lisa murkowski from Alaska, is supporting
Palin's Democratic opponent. And you really
do love to see it. It's quite a rare thing here
she is complaining to Steve Bannon. Bannon,
they won't help me. Even Republican Lisa
murkowski is supporting a Democrat. This
is a delight. My friends.
Speaker 3:
The big, big bucks that are coming in
to say Lisa murkowski's race for Senate,
even though she's not a Republican, she just she
actually is out the other day not voting for me
in my race. She's not voting for the Republican
Party and actually literally announcing that she's
voting for the Democrat in my congressional race
so that I don't win. That's what I'm up against.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Well, listen, it is a delight.
It's rare for a sitting Republican to back any
Democrat. And in particular when you're
a sitting Republican, as is Murkowski,
who is up for reelection in two weeks and
she's supporting the Democrat in that race,
Mary Paul Tola. Lisa murkowski cannot
stand Sarah Palin. That's what's going on.
Palin quit halfway through her term as governor
of Alaska. It rubbed tons of Alaskans the wrong
way. They don't like a quitter. Lisa murkowski
doesn't like a quitter. And Lisa murkowski,
I mean, listen, it's sort of like the the
Susan Collins thing, right? Lisa murkowski
will sometimes say slightly more sane things than
many other Republicans. At the end of the day,
she mostly still votes with Republicans, but
she doesn't like Palin and she's not voting
for Palin. And Palin seems to be losing very, very
badly. There's a new article from the bipartisan
report from a few weeks ago, and it has the latest
polling data. And the key paragraph is this one.
Paul Tola starts in round one because they have
ranked choice voting, voting in Alaska. Paul Tola
starts in round one, meaning initial results with
almost a majority. The progression of the results
puts Powell Tola against Begich for a final
tabulation. Unlike the results from the special
election that gave Powell Tola her currently
unfolding stint in Congress when Palin made it to
the end. And these results Powell told of finished
with 54% of the support Begich had 45 eliminating
Begich before the final round instead of Palin.
Still show Republicans losing with Powell tola
nabbing 56% of support. There evidently wasn't
enough crossover among the Republicans supporters
on either side. And this is the signal. This
is the data on which it is believed that Sarah
Palin is just not consolidating enough support
to actually win this. And 65% of Alaskans express
negative feelings about Sarah Palin. So it is
not looking good. I believe this is the end of
Sarah Palin's political career. If indeed she
loses this election. Let's hope that she does. We
have viewers in Alaska, Alaska, a unique state
in a lot of ways culturally, geographically,
etc.. I believe Palin will lose all the evidence
is that she will lose and hopefully that will
be the end in terms of hearing from Sarah
Palin and her political career. Let's hope.